hey you joining us on the line is Brian
Kilmeade he's author of the brand new
book Sam Houston and the LMO Avengers
this is just the latest in Brian's
series of historical books it's really a
fantastic fantastic piece when Brian
thanks much for joining the show really
appreciate it it's my honor are you
kidding so why don't we just jump right
into the content of the book so there
are a lot of people who actually don't
know all that much about Texas history
if you're outside the state of Texas I
grew up in California obviously you just
kind of know that Texas is part of the
Union but you don't know much about the
history of Texas how it wasn't Republic
before it was ever part of the United
States
so what your book is about basically the
battle that decided the Texas was going
to be independent of Mexico but it
starts off before that so what exactly
happened to lead up to the battle
between the people who would become
Texans and the and the government of
Mexico and then you were kind enough to
have me on in past books and one thing I
try to do pattern these books off is the
Rocky movies and what's the best thing
about the Rocky movies they flashed back
to the previous movies to start the next
one so I thought man I got the idea
about doing Sam Houston because all as
you study Andrew Jackson he keeps
referencing 21 year old Sam Houston but
for tremendous potential when they saw
it they saw so much of each other in
each other I thought well I have an idea
if I get this passed and we decide to do
this because I'm also doing this series
for Fox nation called what made America
great so I was doing an Alamo feature
anyway I go if there's enough here I
know how I'm starting it I'm gonna
flashback to the Battle of Horseshoe
Bend 1814 with his reckless courageous a
six foot three inch blue-eyed young
officer fighting under Andrew Jackson
fear nothing I got wounded three times
in the span of three hours and after he
had hit the first time they brought him
to the sickbay then Jackson wanted to
finish off the battle that night good
can anyone here fight up comes Houston
again Jackson this guy's amazing
it's the first guy over the wall on the
last surge gets killed Sam Houston goes
over the wall and gets hit right away
again so what he does is he should have
died he survived and he learned a couple
of things number one he you saw how
fragile our country is because he
watched Washington burned to the ground
he thought our country was here forever
was gonna be the superpower
and he said oh my god how close do we
get to losing number two you're
encouraged it's great but Kurt's got to
be calculated and I go that's that's the
premise now tell the story and the other
story is that I was ready I don't know
if you have ever experienced blowback
I'm kidding of course you do so book
about when you write a book about Texas
from the American perspective everyone's
gonna say how you don't understand we
stole Texas that's wrong as you know
Jefferson and Jackson among the two
esteemed people who believed that came
to the Louisiana Purchase and that we
never should have given it up and
exchanged for Florida that you know they
did longitude and latitude not States
and they said it was clear as day that
that was it we just doubled the size of
our country we didn't know how we were
gonna handle this it was a bit of a
surprise as you know and we know I'm
gonna hell that so no one really got
caught up in it but it was burned
Jackson because he felt like you won
Florida and you stood in him and James
came polka Buchanan and Martin Van Buren
used to sit on the Hermitage porch and
talk about how they were gonna get Texas
and then Houston goes down there
throughout his life ups and downs up and
down he just ends up being the 40
something year old at the perfect time
and the perfect place with the right
experience to take this group of tough
guys who were determined to avenge the
loss of the Alamo where everybody was
killed including two of the most famous
Americans Davy Crockett and Jim Bowie
and a vengeance in a matter of months I
thought you know the Alamo because you
and I I grew up in New York here in
California
they gave us one day on the Alamo in
social studies so I say let's go beyond
and Ken Burns was the one who told me
because this is lightly reported outside
Texas he said you do Battle of San
Jacinto where they actually won in 17
minutes finished him off in two hours
and then caught Santa Ana it the most
remarkable victory you can imagine and
people tell you I never heard of that
story and most people told me I never
heard of this story
that's exactly right I mean again the
book is really detailed and it gives all
of this background so let's start with
the Battle of the Alamo
everybody knows remember the Alamo but
people don't actually know what that
means what happened at the Alamo why
were Americans even there in the first
place and what was their relationship
with the with the government of Mexico
and and the relationship of the
government of Mexico with the government
of Spain so what's the backstory there
so Moses all sit around 1820 I don't
know if you've no doubt history it's
amazing how the rich become poor almost
overnight bankruptcy from everything to
bankruptcy everything to bankruptcy
so Moses Austin loses everything and
says just like the entrepreneurial
spirit you know
Texas got all this promise no one's
there Comanche Indians have so many
people in that region afraid to go there
so why don't I go down and try to cut
cut a deal with the local Spanish
authority and through fits and starts he
finally gets a deal by true luck but he
gets sick on the way back and he gets
sick and it's last to one of his lasting
wishes was that stephen f austin
addict come out of the north and go and
take his mission of settling then
fulfilling this deal of we but what you
belong to spain you belong to eventually
mexico you take the land you work the
land no slaves no taxes for ten years
and become a catholic ok so everyone
comes down there it's this wonderful
land called texas we now Texas and they
start building up and they start
prospering like never before more than
anything south of them and as strong as
anything north of them and people keep
coming down because blue they're not
been even though we with a new world
people wanted a new world after the new
world they wanted a fresh start after a
fresh start and as far as I could tell
there was no social safety net Nancy
Pelosi wasn't writing guaranteed checks
for not doing anything there was a there
was rumor of a PPP program but I have
not got a confirmation on that so they
actually went down there with a wagon
a rake and a gun and they said that's
all I need that's the attitude of Texas
what I found so interesting is the way
the movies characterized these people is
exactly right it's not a free consent a
mischaracterization these people were
tough as nails they demanded nothing
they all looked out for each other and
it grows and prosperous and everything
would have been fine separate from
America they would do it until Santana
takes over Mexico gets its independence
and this guy go the freedom and liberty
not in a hundred years well my people be
ready for that the Texians are my people
so little by little he was going to let
them know no no no did no elections
there'll be a lot of taxes right away
and no due process doesn't really fly
for Americans
game on few skirmishes leads up to the
Alamo and when you are a hundred eighty
guys and you holding up three thousand a
standing trained Army for 13 days you
get yourself you live in infamy
especially knowing that the old died and
they stared death in the face and they
stood strong in together so that's we
did it but then what happened after when
I Bao San Jacinto kind of rewarded their
valor so let's talk about the Battle of
San Jacinto which again is the Forgotten
battle everybody remembers the name of
the Alamo very few people outside of
Texas know the Battle of San Jacinto at
all but it is one of the great American
military victories it ends up being an
American military victory only later
when America actually annexes Texas but
we'll get to that in just a second so
what exactly happened at the Battle of
San Jacinto so what happened is Houston
and I actually did this in the TV
special this tree is still there
Houston's driving everyone crazy because
he keeps going backwards including the
Provisional Texas government like we
paid you and hired you to fight all you
do is run backwards they call it the
runaway scrape you know what because he
knew they weren't ready he knew they
weren't trained he also knew they were
outnumbered so he's looking for momentum
he's looking for organization he
literally was running and hiding and he
was doing with I feel my opinion he was
doing what the Russians did to Napoleon
and Hitler
and they just burned everything and they
burned everything and retreated and the
Mexican army was running out of there
they're running out of supplies no
quartermaster didn't exist
the medical team didn't exist he didn't
care about his people they already care
about feeding him and as they got sucked
in deeper and deeper they got further
and further from their supply lines they
thought they live off the villages but
now Houston took the villages took the
town he went backwards till they get to
this famous oak tree it's a whoosh wait
tree and it goes up like a bee and one
branch went towards our border American
Board Lee unbranched towards San Jacinto
and the rumor is that he says I'm going
he always said he was going others say
that he his men forced them to go so he
goes and reports for battle as usual
Napoleon Napoleon the Napoleon of the
West came out and Santa Anas men got
there and they had a few skirmishes and
I look I do have a man of a standoff and
you go back to the place it's still
there it looks
exactly the same but Napoleon uh but
Santana made a few mistakes he backed
himself up to water
no one can swim they blew up the bridge
there was no way out and he also said
I'm going to be if we don't fight in the
morning we don't fight at all
you see gets up at 10:00 war council
meeting at 12:00 5:00 to 2:30 Santa Anas
people had marched all night they were
sleeping and they had their guns in a
pile so when they mount the charge and
euston the biggest guy there in front so
courageous gets shot off a horse twice
when they get they get within these
lines bend and without a single shot
being fired on him they go over the top
they finish him off in 17 minutes
crushed him in two hours and instead of
killing Santana when they got him the
next day because he dressed like a
peasant and ran and they found him they
didn't kill him they didn't torture him
they said okay we'll treat you like a
prisoner of war get your letterhead out
like you should have treated our guys at
the Alamo they sign over Texas and
basically signs over a provision that
says send the reinforcements back so
basically they won the war said Sam
Houston goes to Louisiana and heals from
his wounds comes back becomes the first
president the first governor so
immediately in the aftermath of this
this obviously doesn't solve all of
Texas's problems Texas is now an
independent republic it is not part of
the United States formally and later
when Texas seeks admission to the United
States it actually leads to this massive
controversy in which Abraham Lincoln
among others is actually against
bringing Texas into the Union because
he's very much afraid that it's really
the southern states in the law in Texas
to become part of America so they can
have another slaveholding stay because
Texas would be open to slavery so maybe
you can talk about the controversy that
attended Texas actually becoming part of
the United States as opposed to
remaining an independent republic on the
american continent
I was surprised a little I knew I
thought I knew about leading up to the
Civil War they didn't and this is one of
those stories it throws up the Free
State slave State thing there were
people like Andrew Jackson Sam Houston
Lincoln famous people and not so famous
people Seward the fear that we were
gonna have this Civil War I wanted to do
everything to avoid it people thought
Lincoln was you know a racist for not
pushing when he became president right
away he said no I'm trying not to form a
civil war there's a way to fade slavery
out to get it out we know it's
wrong but you have the half of the
country's oh it says it's right and half
dozen and your goal is to keep us
together so every time there would be a
mission another state of the territory
let's go over statehood it's like how
would that line up with the balance of
power so for nine years because they
could not heal this controversy and get
a unanimous vote Texas became its own
country constantly in danger of Mexico
taking it back they had to form their
own Navy create their own security
create their own alliances and in a
typical trumpian like move Sam Houston
courting and vice versa the British to
come in and Brisco hey you got a problem
I'd love to get back in there if you
want I'll take care I'll provide the
Navy and security Mexico will never
bother you again and why don't we work
out a trade relationship right away
well that really spurred the movement of
Texas as a state because the last thing
people want is an additional footprint
of Britain in the southern part of this
hemisphere which was early they were
still up in Oregon so he said yeah guys
I'm probably gonna go with Britain
unless you guys make a decision soon
they made a decision in nine years later
they were part of the country so what do
you make of all the critiques obviously
of Texas becoming part of the countries
you know the revisionist history of
Texas is that it was an imperialist move
by basically white Europeans to take
over indigenous territory or Mexican
territory and there are many people in
sort of the Howard Zinta fied arenas of
American history who think that Texas
really should not be part of the United
States similar they think a lot of the
Southwest should not be part of the
United States in the process of writing
the book what do you make of those
criticisms well then first up we back up
they don't think we should be part of
the United States they don't think it
should exist let's be so there's nothing
that we can ever do to convince them of
this this is what I would say this is
think Colfax stephen f austin was a
master deal maker he wanted to stay as a
province of Mexico and even though they
changed power and he watched the
independents take place he went down to
cut a deal when he says listen this is
the deal my dad sign that I've been
living up to before the letter of the
law the one thing they didn't do in all
honesty and candor they said no slaves
they did have slaves down there not a
great number they were there but having
said that the house didn't bother
Santana at all and basically they had
their own slaves they would people but
basically the serf
they had no chance of any type of
semblance of making a living education
but having said that he went down there
to kind of deal ago we do not want
independence we just want to be an
independent province of the Mexico
Confederacy or whatever you want to call
it they put him in jail they said you'll
listen to me you'll do what we say and
then they're watching what they do the
other provinces at certain rising up
they were killing everybody to send a
message to the Texians to wise up and
get along but they didn't they doubled
and tripled down and the early
skirmishes were victories for the
Texians they take the Alamo and then
they lost the Alamo and he won the gang
send a message he thought by killing
everybody that he would send a message
and get everybody else to quit that
might have worked in some provinces but
not this one then they said we're gonna
fight for this we're gonna fight for our
own independence they rode up using the
template of American independence and
the constitution of Arts Constitution
and these were 99% Americans and some
very Lloyd loyalty on us and they fought
hard and they became their own country
that's just the fact and if you stephen
f austin came out of prison and came
back and he goes I know I've been
telling you we got to stay with our deal
not anymore
game on this is this is a new regime in
there we can't deal with these guys the
book is Sam Houston in the Alamo
Avengers the Texas victory that changed
American history Brian by Brian Kilmeade
is a fantastic read so Brian what do you
think has been the lasting impact aside
from obviously Texas becoming part of
the country Texas has a different view
of itself than than many other states
across the United States like as I say
I'm from California born and bred you
think of yourself as an American first
and a Californian second when I speak
with Texans that that isn't always the
case there are a lot of Texans who sort
of think of themselves
we're Texans first and then Americans
and and and that's sort of the order in
which it goes what sort of independent
mentality do you think has been bred in
Texas because of the origins of Texas
this is my opinion oh is it the reason
why I was gonna do this I was just gonna
try and do a series on Fox nation I do
this thing what made America great I got
21 features done and I was gonna just do
it
and just like stay in the area and do it
and I they were so into me telling this
story and then what I did is but I think
you could appreciate this I would send
him extra
as I was running it and I would give him
a few bucks I say guys go over this make
sure this is your story and I find that
they are prideful but not separatists
they're not like better than America
they just have pride in their original
background that's what struck me I had
just the opposite oppression as a New
Yorker going through school and whatever
I'm doing with my career but when you
dive into it and meet the historians and
the relatives when I was on tour we must
had 11 stops when used to be able to do
a book to her I had 11 stops in Texas I
did not have a line that didn't have 10
or 15 people related to somebody in that
battle or someone who was one of the
first families to get there but they
didn't say look how good I am America is
lucky to have me we're part of the
American story but we had a story before
we became part of America no arrogance
just pride I have not felt any
differently from the myth that the
thousands of people I met there and the
expert in scholars that helped me so I
wasn't asking more broadly about writing
history so you've written a bunch of
books on history at this point and
they're all fantastic you should check
all of them out Brian Kilmeade stuff is
really terrific I don't sense that a
Pulitzer is anywhere in your future I
have a feeling that I may have less to
do with the quality of your books than
it has to do with the quality of the
Pulitzer at this point and they gave the
posters you know this year in commentary
to the the head of the 16:19 project and
call Hannah Jones for original sister II
of the United States that essentially
argues that the United States was
founded on slavery and evil and that
pretty much everything in modern America
is fruit of the poisonous tree as
somebody who studies history and writes
history what do you make of the 1619
project I couldn't be more disappointed
especially the coverage you got I think
that um it may impromptu my next project
to be honest but I just say I'm just
astounded on how much people seem to be
invested in running down America and not
only say we're not exceptional we might
be the worst and that's another example
of it no one would ever excuse slavery
no one would ever say hey on second
thought I wasn't going to get no not in
that in one month it's astounding to
think that the smartest people around
they did so many brilliant things they
chained
the course of human history there was a
beacon of freedom it gave the idea that
so many others to have this form of
government and made people demand this
type of freedom and liberty could
possibly rationalize this behavior but
to think America was built on it's
totally wrong what I think that one
thing is is great is we should look back
on it understand it huge mistake as
George Bush sentenced the original sin
but we've done a lot of good along the
way and still we were built on a solid
foundation
I believe our Constitution was not live
up to it's not that our Constitution was
lacking and none other than frederick
douglass believed the same thing he said
look in the beginning i thought wow this
country wrote slavery Annies the more he
studied it the more he looked at it he
said no it's up to this country to live
up to their founding fathers ideals even
though some had slaves the other thing I
found out too is we didn't have the
market cornered on slaves
it wasn't our idea especially they were
more in Brazil than anywhere else and
around the globe not to excuse the
behavior but we are so much more than a
country that had slaves that I used to
know where to start and the reason why I
wouldn't get a Pulitzer is because they
don't deserve it I'm looking to write to
a mass audience that is so busy and it's
so diverse and as so many other things
going on so they'd be to be perfectly
comfortable answering the question when
asked at a cocktail party or tailgate
are we exceptional nation I want you to
be able to say yes and here's why and
that's why a slice of history told
simply quickly and if you want to know
more I'll tell you exactly where to go
but to me I'm looking to broaden people
out the way I brought now I learned a
ton in my research and that's what I
want I have more people come up to me
great education and say I've never done
that or people say I need go to college
but man this makes me wish I did you
know because I could learn this this is
what I would have majored it so Brian I
would be remiss if I didn't ask you
about some of the news of the day
obviously cover 19 continues to dominate
the news and obviously been raked up and
down by critics particularly of the left
before advocating for easing lock downs
for moving toward a more rash
system that is more sustainable over
time what do you make of the current
debate that's going on in the country
over the sustained lockdown over Kovan
19 and what do you think are rationale
policies people should be pursuing right
now so one thing do you do better than
anybody else you see the common
arguments you need go deeper and try to
take a different nuance to it but I
would have to say and I think you might
back me up on this this is the most
unique argument yet today I mean think
about this we're in a country that
freedom and liberty we all recognize
that Kove it as a danger we all
recognize the nuances of it gotta wear a
mask not a social distance okay no
fighting okay you want to do it miss
okay fine want me to keep 20 20 feet
around okay fine when it comes to the
workplace you want Plexiglas or you want
the cubicles gotta be okay fine but when
it comes to opening up in the pace we
open up it has everything to do is how
quick our country will recover if we
don't recover quickly then you want a
world in which China rules literally
time is not on our side time is not a
luxury safely maturely moving towards
opening up these states should be the
goal I talked to Dan Patrick today on
the radio and he says listen I want to
do everything the same as anything he's
70 years old and he said I'm probably
susceptible to somebody that might get
it might not have a positive outcome I'm
willing to take my chances
by doing the precautions but at the same
time it's lazy to sit in your Statehouse
and shut it down it's easy to do and
it's lazy get out
use your mayors walk down Main Street
find out why we can't open up the
carwash why can't I open up the sports
store why can't I get bait and tackle
why can't I cannot get four people in a
boat why can't I play golf and not
tennis no one has answers to that that
doesn't mean I don't look at the virus
is real I mean people have to have a
quality of life and a chance of economic
survival do you know anyone in there
owns a restaurant yep and the hotel
right now yep but do you know how they
work even on the best day they work 67
hours of Consular and treadmill how dare
we take that away from a virus we had
nothing to do it give them the chance to
make it safe
open up how the criteria open up and do
it
the Dolphins told you how
populated a stadium don't tell the other
tee the other 31 teams can't get people
in that stadium the DA majority came up
with their thing
do you know baseball put together a
genius system for sitting in the dugout
where to stand where to go how'd it go
to two trainers who's gonna be in touch
with whom in the hotel it's genius
they said we want our we want our
industry to thrive this is the only way
to shut it down and to yell at people
and criticize people just because we
want to open it up responsibly is too
stupid for me to even entertain I've had
it with that it's destroying the country
yeah Brian one of the things that's been
astonishing to me is how this has really
become such a politicized issue because
you figure that probably 80% of
Americans 85% of Americans are on board
with this basic idea that if we wear
masks and are not infecting other people
that if we're staying away from other
people for doing responsible things then
being allowed to go out to work or being
allowed to be on the beach and be seven
feet away from somebody else and sit on
a blanket and eat like these are not
controversial things and we all want to
be responsible and yet this has become
very very political and it occurred to
me that one of the reasons it's become
political is because there there are so
many people who actually want America
fundamentally changed and and this is
where things get really ugly
not because I'm accusing these people of
having sort of ulterior motives for the
lock down but because the lock down
tends to support the idea that America
requires fundamental change yourselves
from President Obama over the weekend
when he gave a speech basically
suggesting that the response to
coronavirus demonstrates that America
has always had deep and systemic flaws
and that therefore we need to
fundamentally remake the country along
along that basis that that comes the
pretty dark view of American history and
of the American present that is just not
supportable by fact and yet this because
this virus becomes sort of the
justification for trying to remake the
system that people wanted three months
ago before wouldn't even hit America and
I'm sure you know aoc let that slip out
she thought it was great she came out it
was great they weren't using oil and gas
that you know we had a chance to get
automatic income and then people really
resent not being able to work only in
America can you think it's sacrifice not
to work I'm proud of that statement
about America because we want the honor
of working towards our goals
Pursuit of Happyness and she quickly
went she quickly went down on that she
said I better not say that out loud
oil and gas industry - brought to its
knees she was basically high-fiving
everyone she saw it's all really really
disturbing stuff I think that it's it's
good that most Americans are coming to a
consensus and I'm amused by the the
divide between the American people in
their politicians when it comes to this
sort of stuff and even what the American
people do and what the American people
say you'll see 80 percent approval
ratings for Andrew Cuomo and his
lockdowns then you'll see everybody in
upstate New York basically ignoring his
and people in the middle of Brooklyn
ignoring his lockdowns at the same time
they're saying well we love what Andrew
Cuomo is doing the media divide over
this thing it's not really reflective of
the behavioural divide we saw in New
Jersey today there were a bunch of folks
who went out - who went out to the gym
and the police came and instead of
shutting it down they basically said we
know you're technically violating the
law have a nice day and they took off
and meanwhile Phil Murphy is saying that
they're gonna continue to shut down
until the end of time so it seems to me
that in the end the American people the
spirit of Independence and the American
people is going to remain strong and we
do trust one another not to be
completely stupid about how we handle
this virus which of course is the way
that we actually should treat one
another as sentient human beings capable
of making individual decisions true and
there's going to be people who violate
it just like there are people that are
gonna drink and drive just like when
people say you gotta be off the beach at
sunset and the best days so I'm gonna
sneak on there's gonna be no difference
with this and what happens is the cops
again are in the horrible position of
going up to people and saying don't
sunbathe keep walking on the beach don't
stop my goodness how much pressure do
put on law enforcement we're not gonna
have any policemen left because of
course people turn around go really I
can't sit on a towel in the sand and
three to get my share doesn't matter my
living room and they don't want to do it
yeah Brian Kilmeade the book is Sam
Houston and the Alamo Avengers
definitely go check it out today pick up
copies of all of his other history books
as well he's got George Washington's
secret six in a bunch brother Brian
really appreciate the time and good luck
with the paperback release of the book
which of course was already a New York
Times bestseller one it was in hardcover
and not only do I love you buy your
podcast I like it is the radio show as
well Ben's congratulations on all the
success hey thanks so much Brian go get
him